all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my morning coffee thoughts
where I give my thoughts every morning
coffee
people are kind of walking by so it's a
little awkward but it's okay
um so
I was thinking about how I saw this uh
woman
and I don't know her so this isn't like
a personal thing but I saw her tweet
about something her and her husband did
for like an anniversary right
and
and it really enraged a lot of people
and I I don't get angry right so I you
guys you guys got to think about things
differently
when everyone else that gets mad I ask
why are they mad what is their issue is
it really that they just don't like to
see happy couples being happy couples
because I see these videos go viral all
the time these adorable couples and no
one has a problem
What Men really don't like is overpaying
and I want to give you guys
um and I wanna I Wanna Give You guys an
example
to men Logan Paul is such an atrocity
because this man is paying absolute full
price
for a
now if Nina had to like work for it for
like 10 years and like did all this
stuff for him first you know
um then the guys wanted me to be as
upset but when they see a woman getting
like a
a six digit six digit ring
this is enraging to them when they
haven't seen anything in return
and I think when guys see women
one bragging about the things the men do
for them rather than the men
it signals the truth which is
you know as women were pretty
materialistic and it isn't really about
the guy it's a lot more often about what
he can do for us and the lifestyle
um and I think
other thing I think
is again it's the overpaying most of
these women now I don't know this chick
in particular but
are in their 30s getting this crazy
treatment
and the men look at this and they're
like
why are these men overpayed
and this frustrates the guys okay
third thing
it messes up the natural order of the
world
because the natural order of the world
is supposed to be
men women children okay the women are
supposed to look up to the men
and when you have the men buying all
these trips doing all this stuff for the
chick
it kind of messes it up you know it kind
of messes up the especially like a
30-something year old
you know it it messes up the the order
um
now I don't even know if this chicks in
her 30s so I don't even know about her
but you you guys see the point the
average wife is like 31 years old and
men are are paying full price
for what not overpaying and men can't
stand over paying like if there's one
thing I can think about my dad growing
up
it's that this man wasn't gonna overpay
for everything he was a
multi-millionaire Rich ass dude and you
could not get this man I remember we
drove
on all vacations
we never flew we always drove
because men just cannot there's like
something in their being when they see a
man overpay or they have to overpay
themselves it like pisses them off
so I think the reason
that men get mad when they see these
guys
doing all this for women so like
buying them trips 250
000 engagement ring when that when that
woman
um you know they seemed like a really
cute couple but when that woman was like
you know he was like that's an expensive
ring like what did you do for him
you know our grandmothers and
great-grandmothers used to easily rattle
off like 10 things that they did now
it's not really our fault we were raised
in this Society didn't teach us but
but you know now you have grown women
getting offended
when asked what they do
now think of the equivalent of this okay
think of the equivalent the equivalent
of this is going to a job interview and
getting offended when they ask what do
you do for him or what do you do for
your boss a good employee is going to be
like well I do this this this and this a
bad employee is going to get offended
um you know you could have someone on
their first day and say I don't know how
to do anything
but I'm willing to learn and that's an
attitude most mental take but when they
see these guys
putting these women on pedestals that
they don't deserve they get pissed off
because it inflates the market
and a lot of times it's young guys who
don't know any better
um
so you know
I think that's why they get pissed off
when they see a lot of this stuff men
are just sick of they're sick of the
overpaying
and these dudes are just so inflate in
the market I don't think it's like they
just hate the women they just hate these
these red pill doomers no I think
they're just they're tired of overpaying
I think that's it
and they're tired of seeing these chicks
get this crazy lifestyle for men they
divorce seven years later it's and you
could say that's Doom and Gloom
but I mean
you know guys I'm gonna I have I have a
really big update in the Crowder case
you guys are gonna be the first
that woman
was working a hundred hours or sorry
that woman was a stay-at-home wife with
a nanny working a hundred hours a week
a hundred imagine being a
multi-millionaire and having to pay a
nanny a hundred hours a week because
your wife can and refuses to do anything
I mean guys
um this is the world we're living in
where women don't even want to raise
their own kids
and then they're getting these crazy
rings in this crazy lifestyle for what
now I'm not even saying it's the women's
fault completely uh what did our mothers
teach us our grandmothers not much and a
lot of them put in this fear stuff so
they put in like
you know you need a backup plan
um so it's not even necessarily our
fault but you know that that's the men's
point of view I'm gonna say
no they don't just want to see your
relationships fail they don't really
care about you that much yes when they
see a happy couple where the woman is in
order they're happy about it they're not
doom and gloomers but the problem is the
overpaying
tell a man tell a man he has to pay they
hate sales because it just reminds them
that the price goes down and up like
guys hate that stuff it works on women
not men but let me know what you guys
think maybe I'm just a doom and gloomer
I was just I was just thinking about why
um like the video you know and also
we're going to do a meet up in London in
like two weeks so if you want
to meet me meet all the people from the
show one did two weeks subscribe to the
channel
bye